$20,000 that's what I'm gonna pay you to  kill him a lot the devil comes to me  I've been watching you  this is destined a residents are advised  to stay indoors  we got a hurricane you biscuit a country  all signs clearly point to you being the  murderer tell me what happened I didn't  do anything  [Music]  is it true that's your wife don't treat  you right he was  - drives me insane  I know you got this in here we've had  the sweet touch of love we ain't down  now if you got a dark side darker than  the hell  [Music]  you'll have to trust me see what you did  you expect me to believe you didn't  commit murder  look at our basement  what's he talking about he's a pasta  okay  [Music]  you  you